good morning believe nation today's
message is execute your vision so this
is an interesting clip for me I don't
necessarily agree with the start of his
clip or he's saying people don't like to
be pioneers they don't like to be the
first I like being the first I like
being a pioneer you know pioneers like
being pioneers I think a lot of you guys
as entrepreneurs we like doing new stuff
we like being pioneers we like being the
first it can even be the motivation like
if somebody else goes out and does it
you don't want to do it anymore because
you're not the first I get that it's not
for everybody though and some people
don't like that risk and some people
don't like being pioneers but where I
really really agree with him is that
it's not easy people think is gonna be
easy people look at the videos and they
read the magazines and they maybe watch
you know Shark Tank and you think my
idea is way better than that guy I'm Way
smarter than that guy you think back to
people you went to school with my god
that guy was such a dropout like I'm Way
smarter I could do way better and then
you go and you start it and you don't
have success where you have to respect
the game if you disrespect the game it
will own you you know entrepreneurship
is tough it's not going to be easy and
the thing that gets you through is the
vision the thing that gets you through
is the love for what you're doing the
thing that gets you through is you just
have to get it done you will will it
into existence you will
do it even if it wasn't making you money
because you love doing it so much and
that's where you hone your craft that's
when you get really good at what you're
doing that's when you differentiate
yourself that's when you really stand
out it's because you're forced to do it
you're forced by yourself to do it it
makes you do something differently
because the way everybody else is doing
it may not work for you and you're not
getting great results you're not really
like when you love something so much and
it just doesn't exist or doesn't exist
like you want it to exist because you
have a vision then it does crazy things
to you it it pushes you to go off and do
things that maybe you didn't even think
we're possible or the friends and family
around you didn't think we're possible
and so you have to find that thing that
you can get so excited about you have to
find that vision that when you look at
you are so passionate about it that you
have to go out and make that happen and
you will not stop until you do it and
not enough people have that people have
a hobby business yeah that's okay extra
income you know whatever you're never
gonna build anything spectacular world
impacting massively money-making unless
you have a deep love for it and a
compelling vision for where you want to
take this thing so the question they
today is what's the vision for your
business what do you want to accomplish
what's the big dream big goal that you
have that you're so fired up amped up
super excited by leaving the comments
below I will join in the discussion
finally I want to give a quick shout out
to Barry Ashe crop to order more copies
on my book Barry thank you so much I
really appreciate that I don't have any
gift these off to people but I really
appreciate your support in my endeavor
to spread the word about this book
spread the word I like that so for your
chance at a shout out in the future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book and email in your receipt so we can
keep track thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event special
I spray so give me go